a very big breaking news uh donald trump
ivanka trump and donald trump jr have
been subpoenaed by the new york attorney
general
this is uh we are talking about leticia
james who is the democrat leticia james
has been investigating uh the trump
organization for possible financial
crimes and we have learned yesterday
that subpoenas have been issued for
donald trump ivanka trump and donald
trump jr now what is that issue here as
a reminder
is
the oh what's the right word i mean is
it is it scamming is it lying is it's
the
widely at this point accepted
allegation that we heard from michael
cohen and others
that donald trump would
lie one way or the other the trump
organization would deceive one way or
the other about the value of properties
in order to achieve whatever goal they
had so basically the way it works is as
follows imagine that you have a building
that's actually worth 25 million dollars
just as an example let's say you have a
25 million dollar building
if you want to get a loan
and you want a 35 million loan
when the bank says what's your
collateral you say i've got this
building that's worth 50 million now
it's really only worth 25 but you say
it's worth 50 so you can safely give me
a loan of 35 million against it but when
the tax authorities come to you and they
say hey
this building it's worth 25 million so
you're going to have to pay property tax
on the basis of a 25 million dollar
value you say no no no this building is
only worth 10 million this is a crappy
little building
and you argue that it is worth less in
order to reduce your tax liability and
that is of course fraud it is fraud to
to do that um and that is one of the
elements that is being investigated by
the attorney general leticia james they
have previously requested that donald
trump appear
we have now learned that they have
issued a subpoena for donald trump and
two of his adult children to appear and
they have already announced their plans
to refuse abc is reporting eldest
children won't comply with subpoenas
from new york attorney general
donald trump jr and ivanka trump are now
respondents in the civil case they have
refused to comply with subpoenas issued
by the new york state attorney general's
office as it conducts a civil
investigation into the way the family
real estate business valued its holding
a dispute has arisen between the oag and
the individual trump parties regarding
the subpoenas the document filed jointly
by new york attorney general leticia
james and an attorney for the trump
organization said don jr and ivanka will
now be named as respondents in the
inquiry which parallels a criminal
investigation by the manhattan district
attorney's office
as her investigation into financial
dealing with the trump organization
continues attorney general james is
seeking interviews under oath of donald
trump trump jr and ivanka
despite numerous attempts to delay our
investigation by the trump organization
we are confident that our questions will
be answered and the truth will be
uncovered because no one is above the
law
donald trump jr and ivanka trump sought
to quash the subpoenas monday evening in
emotion
alan feuderfoss the attorney
representing the trump children
questioned the motives her office is
also involved in the criminal
investigation of trump he wrote the goal
of the subpoenas is all too clear she
seeks to circumvent the entire grand
jury process and nullify moving parties
most fundamental constitutional and
statutory rights by requesting they
provide non-immunized testimony to the
office of the attorney general when they
and the district attorney of new york
are jointly conducting a grand jury
investigation so there's a couple
different legal opinions here
one legal opinion is
the ability of congress to enforce
subpoenas is somewhat vague
but the ability here to enforce
subpoenas
is uh unquestioned there is no legal
question as to the ability of the
enforcer the ability to enforce these
subpoenas
but at the same time
they can show up
and invoke their fifth amendment rights
and um there are some limitations to
that one lawyer i spoke to said you know
you can really only invoke your fifth
amendment rights when it is reasonable
to believe that speaking could actually
incriminate you that there are
circumstances where
what you are being asked about could not
reasonably be considered to incriminate
you and thus invoking your fifth
amendment right um would would not be
okay
here
it genuinely does seem that they may
have been involved in criminality and so
the likelihood that if they were pushed
and forced to respond to the subpoena
and provide testimony that they would
invoke their fifth amendment rights if
you ask 10 different lawyers there's ten
different opinions about this and so
ultimately we have to wait and see but
much like all of the other things we've
seen so far this may also get no
traction but
but
the fact that there were subpoenas is
certainly noteworthy and over the next
24 to 48 hours
we we may well learn more about the fate
of these subpoenas some say the walls
are closing in
i still don't think trump sees a day of
jail or prison i i just don't see it i'm
not going to blow smoke in your nose or
up anywhere of yours we'll have more
coverage of this on our instagram which
you can find at david pakman's show
leave a comment there and let me know if
you think anything will come of this
one of our sponsors is self
self-decode is a genetic testing and
analysis platform that gives you tools
to gain insights about your health based
on your dna this is a new technology
we're still learning so much about
what of substantive value can we get
from these types of results but by using
artificial intelligence and machine
learning you can get personalized
insights based on your specific dna as
well as getting lab test analysis and
recommendations really a lot of
interesting ways to get information
about yourself through the self-decode
platform they never sell your
information they never give away your
information to anybody self-decode sent
me a dna kit to get my saliva i did the
test sent it back and in just a few
weeks i had my results i found for
example that genetically i'm not at big
risk for kidney stones
not at big risk for asthma
unfortunately i'm at slightly increased
risk of headaches which is true which is
true and the recommendations you get are
really simple and logical things
relating to sleep relaxation etc very
very interesting and this is a
technology that's going to develop and
mature significantly over the next five
to 10 years self-decode is giving my
audience 25 off when you click the link
below and use the coupon code pacman